bien ya tenemos un muñeco de nieve para
comenzar a trabajar ahora podemos llegar
a las verdaderas entrañas del software
de articulación necesitamos definir de
formadores de traslación rotación y
rescala miento para poder mover tus
figuras y aquí es donde entran en juego
las funciones
recuerda las funciones agrupan series de
operaciones o procedimientos que
usaremos muchas veces las funciones
aceptan entradas sobre las que se
realizan un conjunto de operaciones
ahora para construir cualquier
deformador necesitamos una función que
acepte dos entradas primero deben
aceptar un par de coordenadas que forman
un vértice de nuestra figura luego
aceptan un valor que es la magnitud de
la transformación que queremos aplicar
por ejemplo el de formador trasladar x
podría aceptar una coordenada digamos 22
y para la segunda entrada proporcionamos
un valor de digamos 5 dentro de esta
función trasladar x las matemáticas que
se hacen son bastante sencillas suman 5
a la coordenada x lo cual ahora nos da
72 ese es un proceso para la
transformación de cada vértice de la
figura claro que nuestras figuras
contienen muchos vértices por ejemplo
nuestro sombrero tiene 8 y eso significa
que su función se ejecuta ocho veces una
para cada vértice todas las funciones de
formadoras transforman vértices usando
ecuaciones
y la transformación depende de los tipos
de ecuaciones utilizadas en tus
funciones las ecuaciones usadas para el
rescate mientras rotación y la
traslación son todas diferentes unas de
otras
estas las cubrimos a detalle en nuestra
elección de escenarios y montajes
en la próxima revisión de código verás
un ejemplo de cómo escribir una función
de traslación
luego en el ejercicio te dejaremos
escribir funciones de formadoras sin
restricciones muy bien ahí nos vemos